У березні минулого року ЄС надав громадянам Грузії безвізовий режим
і кількість подань на отримання притулку зросла мало не втричі.
Найбільше прохань зареєстровано в Саксонії та Північному Рейні-Вестфалії.
Центр розміщення претендентів на статус біженця
знаходиться на заході Дрездена.
Дорога сюди веде через не найпрестижніший квартал.
У цій будівлі розміщено близько п'ятисот біженців -
і приблизно кожен п'ятий з Грузії.
Намагатися поговорити з кимось із них марно -
стороннім вхід заборонено, охорона наганяє журналістів,
самі біженці не налаштовані на інтерв'ю.
У Саксонській раді з питань біженців напружену
ситуацію навколо цього гуртожитку пояснюють так:
За останні два роки в центрі на Гамбургер штрасе
ми регулярно спостерігаємо конфлікти із застосуванням насильства.
Біженці постійно скаржаться на умови утримання.
Вони кажуть, що санітарно-гігієнічна ситуація погана,
цілі родини туляться в одній кімнаті, санітарні приміщення -
туалети та ванні кімнати - не закриваються, а служба безпеки проводить обшуки.
Все це плюс відсутність особистого простору
викликає у людей стрес і призводить до того, що конфлікти переростають у бійки.
Чому грузини так активно домагаються статусу біженця у Німеччині?
Етері Хахман виросла у Тбілісі, живе в Німеччині вже вісім років, юрист за освітою.
Вона вважає, що насамперед ідеться про економічні причини.
Проблема у тому, що в нас немає соціальної системи,
як у німців, коли вони, приміром, отримують гроші, коли у них з'являються діти.
Коли в них завжди є якась страховка, наприклад,
коли вони не працюють, вони отримують гроші.
У нас у Грузії такого немає ...
І ще різниця у зарплатах - у нас дуже низькі зарплати.
Етері Хахман іноді працює перекладачем у судах,
де стикається ще з одним аспектом міграції - кримінальним.
У нас є такі люди, які приїжджають з Грузії,
або з Чечні, або з Росії теж, і вони працюють разом, скажімо так, по магазинам...
Що вони роблять? Крадіжки - ось що вони роблять!
І інші нехороші речі.
У зв'язку зі зростанням кримінальної активності
влада Північного Рейну-Вестфалії навіть пропонувала
заморозити через це безвізовий режим для Грузії.
Така можливість у Німеччини є.
Але поки до цього вирішили не вдаватися.
Проте Грузію можуть включити у список так званих безпечних країн.
Це спрощує екстрадицію.
За даними МВС Саксонії, на кінець серпня в регіоні
перебувало понад 500 громадян Грузії, яким було
відмовлено в притулку і наказано залишити країну.
Місцева влада організувала вже два чартерні рейси
у Тбілісі для випровадження тих, кому відмовлено.
Посол Грузії у Німеччині коментує ситуацію так:
За даними посольства, вжиті заходи вже призвели до того,
що кількість заяв про притулок від громадян Грузії стала зменшуватися
у порівнянні з початком року вона скоротилася на 70 відсотків.